hello everyone welcome back to the cup
of Blanca saga we are back at the 1911
tournament in San San Sebastiano and we
have a game between our own names of
each and josé raúl capablanca this is a
game from round 8 in round 7 capablanca
faced old readerís and that game ended
in a draw I decided not show it it's a
really short game some pieces got
exchanged and a draw was agreed upon but
I will put it in the description below
it will be the first thing you will see
so just click on it if you want to check
that a game out as well but this is
round 8 and I don't know if you remember
but in round 1 when couple Blanca played
against also Bernstein Bernstein said
alongside the other names of each that
capablanca should not be allowed to
participate in this tournament as he
didn't win any major tournament so as a
couple Blanca did beat I was a Bernstein
in round 1 it would be you know it would
pretty much shut everyone up if he just
went and beat names of each also but as
you remember names which also objected
to capablanca commenting on his blitz
games
so then Capablanca challenged him to a
series of speed games and then easily
beat aron nimzowitsch but this is
classical chess so it's a it's a little
bit different and i also have a question
for you throughout their lives our own
nimzowitsch and josé raúl capablanca
have played 11 games in total so what do
you think the end result was we're gonna
return to this after the game but you
know something to think about so let's
check out the game which opens with E 4
we have e 6 D 3 and D 5 and it goes
without saying that this is the first
encounter of these two legends so we
have the French defense on the board
Knight to d2 and now C 5 cup of one cup
was always a big fan of this c5 move I
liked Philidor a long long ago always
said that you should always move the
pawn in front of the bishop before
developing your knight so as the pawn
will not block the knight will not block
the development of the pawn Knight to g2
f3
we have Knight to c6 backup of Blanca
Bishop to e2 and now Bishop to d6 just
developing we have castles Queen c7 by
Capablanca pressuring the h2 pawn rook
to e1 and now Knight to G to e7
we have c3 kappa blanka castles and now
a3 we have F 5 by kappa blanka hitting
that Center and now Bishop to f1 you
have to decide what to do here you don't
really gain anything by capturing
anything you cannot push as the v square
is protected three times by capablanca
so if you're a bishop to f1 waiting to
see what black will do and here black
can capture for example he can go pawn
captures I mean 4d captures and then
push c4 and black has a very nice
position white doesn't really have all
that many choices on how to develop but
the capablanca finds a useful move
Bishop to d7 develops a piece connects
these rooks and also waits to see what
names of each will do and here there
isn't all that much you can do here and
you have to try something so e captures
on d5 undie if I was plated h3 is also a
possibility but if h3 then most like the
kappa blanka would go into that captures
captures and c4 but here we have e
capture some d5 we have each capture
some d5 and not before
here expanding on the Queen side
Capablanca ignores this and goes rook 88
to developing his rook and now Bishop
the b2
we have b6 strengthening c5 and now
comes d4 names of which would very much
like if everything here would just get
exchanged and this dark square bishop
would come alive but Capablanca does not
allow that he plays c4 and here we have
a very interesting moment in the game
you see couple bunkers position he has
two very nice rooks the bishops are very
nicely placed that the Knights are
perfectly fine and the Queen and Bishop
are nicely eyeing that h2 point whereas
you have nimzowitsch the bishop on b2 is
really doing nothing so how do you
develop here it's not all that easy to
decide for example you could try to get
this knight into the game let's say
Bishop e2 but you already played Bishop
from e2 to f1 so this would be like
admitting you made a poor choice but
even
doing this let's say five let's say nice
to f1 you try to develop this way a for
black grabs even more space and the
stifles your position even more of
course you cannot capture due to this
well in Discovery and after Knight to g3
black can even just push you back and
there's really nothing for whites to
look for here mmm you can just see how
much squares just just the black pawns
are controlling in whites camp so here
after this c4 moved back up a blank on
him so which made a very concrete
decision he decided to give up a piece
for two points and a very nice attack so
he played Knight captures on c4 okay you
do have to capture it it is the best
move we have D captures on c4 and now
Bishop captures on c4 so giving up the
night for dew points this also comes
with two Czech kappa blanka goes King to
h8 and now comes nice to g5 and now
there are there are some threats here
night f7 check of course would we need
the rook Queen h5 is an idea threatening
checkmate on h7 so the position is not
without poison and here kappa blanka has
to make a decision does he want to
capture on h2 with checked and the see
what happens there or does he want to
guard f7 by nice to d8 Knight to d8
is possible so yes now you control the
f7 square but after Queen h5 white now
controls the f7 square three times and
you're also threatening checkmate so you
do have to do something about that after
you block with h6 now well you get a
couple of you could try a couple of
things here for example Bishop to f7
will win you some material for example
after Knight captures a knight captures
with check but now black will not
capture black will just play king g8 and
there's no good way to continue your
attack here the knight is attacked twice
there's no good retreat square for the
knight you would have the capture here
and after Queen captures black defendant
black as of material and black will be
winning this game on the other hand
after Queen to H into H 5 after h6 you
could try Bishop to b3 the knight is
pinned so there's no worry about it
being captured
but what white would want to do is play
C for d5 and make this bishop come alive
after this [ __ ]
live den ideas like queen caps or some
h6 become possible so let's see if here
for example Knight g8 you could go see
for preparing d5 and after Knight to
have six kicking the Queen back Queen to
h4 now black also has to make a move
let's say 94 now you try
d5 and here it is a very dangerous
position for example if you capture here
then it's just Queen captures on h6 the
straight out checkmate whether we go to
g8 or block Queen will just capture on
g7 you are getting checkmated here but
again after d5 if you try something like
King to g8 then black will be alright
now you are no longer threatening any
Queen captures on h6 ideas and now after
captures captures captures and captures
it will just be a better position for
black after black captures here you can
looking h1 bishop goes back and there
aren't really any dangerous here for
black but that's a lot of moves you have
to consider and you have to calculate a
lot here and as you all know Capablanca
was a bit lazy when it came to
calculations if he found a different
idea he decided not to calculate so here
he went for a different plan first bunch
of captures on h2 not bothering himself
with this night to f7 check we have King
- h1 and now Bush will be back to f4
attacking the knight forcing the Knights
to deliver this check so ok night to f7
check now you have to capture if you go
if you go King to g8 then Queen to h5
will be very strong also the night gets
defended so we have looked captures
Bishop captures and not rook to a fate
attacking the bishop with bishop back to
h5 and now comes Knights the g8 c4 names
o once the gets this bishop to come
alive Queen to d8 and now if you start
with b5 immediately then Queen to h4
check will be deadly
for example King g1 Queen h2 checking f1
Queen h1 check King moves and now the
Queen no longer guards the bishop on h5
Queen captures and after king d3 black
is just up in material and well white
has a king on d3 so of course it would
be winning for black so after Queen to
d8 you can't go for d5 immediately first
Queen to F
you will always have the opportunity of
going Queen to h3 to block this check
Capablanca delivers it immediately we
have Queen to h4 and now again you have
to block if you go King do you want then
Queen to h2 check King f1 and now a very
nice idea Knight to f6 check not to
check but Knight to f6 will trap the
bishop the g4 square is covered by the
pawn and also the bishop is now attacked
twice so here after d5 attacking the
knight and also the attacker of the
bishop that is the knight on f6 you
could go 95 block the bishop but after
Queen to h3 Queen captures G captures
now you play Knight captures on c4 and
now the bishop on b2 is under attack and
also the bishop on h5 is under attack
you will have to eliminate this attacker
Bishop captures but now 92 check King
moves and after G captures you will have
this position where white black is just
controlling a lot of squares around the
White King capablanca still has two
pieces for the rook rook g8 is coming
the black will be winning this position
so after Queen to h4 check him so he
decides to block immediately Queen to h3
and now comes Knight seat the e7 sorry
first Queen captures on f2 grabbing the
pawn and also attacking the bishop here
so you do have to block this a rope to
e2 this is the best idea
Queen to g3 now forcing a Queen trade
Queen captures and Bishop captures and
now comes c5 d5 also seems like a
reasonable idea but the nimza which has
a very concrete plan he wants to have
this diagonal open for his light square
bishop we have c5 and now Knight seat
the e7 Bishop to f3 by names of H now
the bishop will be very useful in light
squares for when names which starts
pushing is passed pawns but now comes
Bishop to b5 attacking names of each
rook here we have looked the sea tube
and now comes Knight to f6 you can see
how the Knights are very useful in
controlling the light squares here the
these two knights control this course
you cannot push it to the knight and
Bishop control this square so all other
useful pieces placements we have
a for by names of each attacking kapa
Blancas Bishop here we have Bishop to d3
attacking the rook and now it's very
hard to decide what to do with the rook
rook c3 rook d2 will all come in range
of this this Knight jumping to e4 so
here names I which try to rook the c1
but it's it's no better we have nice to
e4 now threatening a lot of very nice
the ideas but the biggest one is I can
tell you the biggest one because I'm
leaving that for the challenge but let's
say here you decides to create a past a
pawn for example you play something like
C captures it doesn't work because of
rope to f6 now roof to h6 will be a huge
threat and now if you play something
like Bishop captures you get Bishop
captures and now whatever you play rock
a three Luke 2 H 6 will be deadly
now let's say King g1 a bunch of h2
check King F 2 and now real characters
and b6 and you are still down in
material and black is black is just
winning this position your B point is
under attack after b5 even rook to g6 in
is an idea threatening g2 so black is
just all over the place but after this
Knights the e4 names of which did not go
for this idea rather he played b5 he
wanted to create a past C pawn but here
he runs into a force to mate in five so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the move Capablanca played
or perhaps he didn't play it but still
you know feel free to find it feel free
to pause the video I will give you a
couple of seconds as usual for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations for especially for those
of you who found the entire sequence but
for those who just want to enjoy the
show the idea is rook to f6 this is what
capablanca played and now everything
becomes obvious names which played
Bishop captures on e4 and here if it
took this Bishop characters on e4 into
consideration and found even the next
move then really congratulations you are
truly awesome but if not feel free to
pause the video here again and try to
find the the forcing line for black here
it's really a really
so you'll you know feel great for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations the move is Bishop to f2
now you simply block gg1 and there is no
defense against rook to h6 for example
if you capture then rope to h6 is
checkmate in 1 and if you don't capture
if you try and give your king some room
for example g3 or g4 doesn't really
matter just Bishop captures still the
two bishops now create a wall King he
has to go to h2 and again rook to h6 is
checkmate so it's very interesting here
after this rook to have six move you can
see where all of names are which species
are placed the rook and c1 rook and a
one Bishop on b2 none of them really
having anything to do with the game
after loop to f6 there is no defense and
well capablanca shows names of each that
the game is actually being played on the
King side not on the Queen side and for
those of you who remember the question
from the beginning of the video I said
that Capablanca and nimzowitsch played
11 games throughout their lives what was
the result
so I don't know what you thought the
result was but after those 11 games six
of the games were drawn nimzowitsch 1-0
games and 5 games were won by capablanca
so quite an impressive result against a
player like our names of which truly
impressive but yeah names which never
was able to want to win a single game
against josé raúl capablanca
yeah this is around 8 of the tooth of
the 1911 tournament in san sebastian
Capablanca still without a loss and it's
going to be very interesting to see how
how this whole thing will turn out and
you know where we're gonna be going with
this whole kappa blanka saga so i do
hope you enjoyed it and that you're
enjoying my wealth so far coverage of
the Capablanca saga i would like to
thank your audience Alex minders Jen's
Federer Kenneth the Sarah and Theo de
Rivaz for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon hopefully what some
more interesting videos
be checking up on well Gibraltar chess
festival and also do-si-do hashtag
suggests on cramming games I still
haven't decided on the one that we are
going to show thank you all and I'll see
you soon